like I feel like you know you know what
we're saying and you know that we're
right but you just kind of like to argue
a little bit not really I think I I have
a lot of
people that have
don't get me wrong like I I don't really
I wouldn't really like my child to say
oh I'm a transgender and I I was really
pissed off when Caitlyn Jenner won a
woman of the year because that really
pissed me off because I'm like like
there are women doing amazing things and
you're gonna give it to a man that just
says
he was a man and then when he
transformed into a woman then why are
you mad it's a woman he hasn't even been
a woman for that long
I thought you said in the beginning that
it's anyone that feels like a woman no
no well I'm saying no the fact that you
won the woman yeah
but